uh players have 15 minutes and then they
start game number two but liam and uh
digloren in the lead in their
quarterfinals now in the question will
magnus carlsen be in the lead after this
or even hans niemann now yeah i mean all
three results are possible despite the
computer saying 0.0
the momentum is all in black's favor
he's turned it around white has
completely lost control
white's king is so open as well but
white still has this extra night so if
he can survive the onslaught
okay this is the second time we've seen
this position we saw a check another
check
is magnus really going to play for the
win he's considering it but only 35
seconds in order to play for the win you
i'd have to go up the board with your
king which looks terrifying or you go
back and you run to the left side of the
board but
okay is he really going to go for it no
he doesn't the players bail out with a
draw
wow
what a well i'm going to say what a game
by hans niemann that's quite impressive
the way he was able to defend and
start attacking